[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm constant in kitten
and this is a show for you if you're
bored with people arguing on the
internet over subjects they know nothing
about a trigonometry we don't pretend to
be the experts we ask the experts are
absolutely fantastic guest this week is
independent economic and political
consultant thinkers Landau welcome to
trigonometry thank you very much great
to be here it is great to have you here
thanks so much for coming we've seen you
talking about many different things over
the years and we were so glad you could
make it
for anyone who unlike us does not know
who you are just tell everybody who are
you how have you come to be sitting in
this chair what's been your journey
through life okay very briefly I was
born in London
some years ago emigrated to Israel 1976
after getting a degree from LSE I've
been living in Israel for all that time
I have been working as a independent
consultant for over 20 years 22 years
something like that in macroeconomics an
increasingly political risk analysis of
Israel and Middle East have always been
very interested in current affairs in
history in British European history have
been on and off at kill Kannamma --xe in
Ireland for since it started in 2009
which is where we met and I visit London
frequently as two usually three or four
times a year so I'm fairly plugged into
what's going on here
well you mentioned being based in
Jerusalem in the Middle East as you said
just before we start to the interview it
seems to be kicking off and you said
wherever you stick a pin on the map
something is happening so give us a
broad overview for people who I mean
it's gonna take about half an hour just
to give us a superficial view of it but
give us a broad overview of the things
that are happening now in the Middle
East okay this is really complicated and
difficult and broad overview you
start with the fact that the dominant
theme in the Middle East today is that
there is a intensifying struggle between
the two key forms of Islam Sunni Islam
and Shiite Islam and without going into
the religion and theology what matters
is that the Sunnis are the vast majority
the key Sony states are Egypt Turkey and
Saudi Arabia Saudi Arabia is important
because it is the site or an in Saudi
Arabia the sites of the key Muslim or
Islamic cities of Mecca Medina and the
that's worthy so a Mohammed lived and so
on
Shiite Islam is centered on Iran Iran
underwent a revolution in 1979 and
became a theocracy which it means that
is run by religious leaders who have a
very extreme version of Shia Islam which
never existed in the past and they are
engaged in seeking to export their
religious revolution throughout the
Middle East and that is causing a great
deal of trouble pretty much everywhere
that is a broad overview the second
thing you need to know about Middle East
today is that the mega event of the last
decade is the strategic decision by the
United States to not entirely withdraw
but to considerably downgrade the Middle
East in the context of American foreign
policy its began under Obama it's been
continued by Trump it will virtually
everybody think that it will continue
irrespective who the next president is
we're seeing a change a fundamental
change in American policy and what that
means in in very simple terms is that
the sheriff has left town and that means
that all the other players who were
previously constrained by the existence
and activity of the sheriff are now much
less constrained and where does Israel
come into all of this
interestingly is much more sidelined by
these de Ville
months whereas if you go back to the
seventies 18 now you go back to the 20th
century second half of the 20th century
the struggle tree in Israel and its
neighbors and Israel and the
Palestinians was very much at the center
of middle-eastern events this has
changed very dramatically in the 21st
century
so the Israel is much more on side lines
Israel Palestine is far far less
important than it was in the view of
pretty much everybody in the Middle East
and what we have seen in recent years is
that Israel has strengthened
considerably its relationship with many
of the Sunni states notably Egypt now
increasingly Saudi Arabia albeit that
still clandestine ray and other Persian
Gulf states such as a man and UAE so all
of the countries which feel threatened
by Iran of which Israel is along with
Saudi Arabia at the top of the list
because the Iranian Revolution has set
as its goal to wipe Israel off the face
of the earth so Israel has been engaged
in a struggle with Iran for some decades
just become much more intense in recent
years and consequently Israel is finding
common ground and many of the Sony
States also threatened by Iran
so Israel's position has changed
dramatically and in some senses becomes
stronger because it is part of a
regional quasi alliance and why do you
think that America supports this
withdrawal or in the Middle East because
normally you know America at a very
strong presidents thought you said why
is it now they're going right no more we
want out this is a reaction to first and
foremost the invasion of Iraq which
proved to be a very very costly mistake
costly in both the financial and human
sense and in the political sense
so after 9/11 Americans invaded
Afghanistan worse things go very well
but the object was to destroy the
Taliban movement there which they failed
to do and then Bush for whatever reasons
decided to invade Iraq and remove the
Saddam Hussein regime which militarily
was easily accomplished but what then
turned out was that they had no
follow-up plan so the Americans made
very serious blunders in the first
decade of this century and in the
current decade what was seen as a
tremendous reaction to that on the part
of the general public and most of the
leadership they don't see they regret
there are some things they've done they
think they were counterproductive and
that's one way of putting it in a
strategic sense and and they it goes
much deeper than that
in American culture the American culture
is very black and white as you seen very
many contacts and Americans tend to say
okay we're going to go in and do this or
do something somewhere and if it doesn't
work they leave I'll give you a very
different example but it's it's very
indicative right in the 1990s in the
decade of the 1990s Merrill Lynch which
was then the biggest brokerage company
in the United States twice
decided to go into Canada talk about
somewhere far away they said to
establish themselves in Canada they did
it they said no there's somebody else
coming
it's mistake we're losing money we're
leaving few years later now we really
want to be in Canada went back into
Canada now it's not working relief it's
a mindset which to Europeans is very
strange very short-term very kind of
bond bottom-line oriented but that's how
they work
and Pincus do you think it's also as
well that the Americans swallowed this
idea that you can import democracy
everywhere all we need to do overthrow
the regime pulling democracy hey presto
you've got a democratic state and what
Iraq showed them is that this was a load
of nonsense
yes well I think one of the things I
find interesting you're talking about
how Israel is essentially building
relationships with the Sunni States it's
almost like you've got perfect
multiculturalism in the Middle East
you've got the Jews and the Muslims
working together anything perfect in the
Middle East let alone multicolored you
have any kind of functional
multiculturalism is in Israel where
there's a large Muslim majority who are
increasingly integrating the economy
finally Anna was a minority has a
minority right in Parliament and in the
general in the system so Israel is the
only country in the Middle East where
the Christian minority is not only
hanging in there but actually thriving
to some degree and not being driven out
as it is in virtually every other
country in the Middle East so in many
respects multiculturalism insofar as it
exists in the Middle East is is very
much an Israeli phenomenon and that's
just in the kind of cultural religious
thing then of course you have the fact
that gays in Israel are a clear movement
who who were working for their rights
and except in Assam which is again
stands in somewhat sharp Concord
distinction to the situation many other
come to put it more crudely they're not
being thrown off buildings in Israel and
like pretty much everywhere else
Pinkus why is it I go on my Facebook
Timeline many of whom are populated by
left-wing liberals and they portray to
me that Israel is a great evil of the
world and the reason why the Middle East
is so unstable
why does Israel have this reputation and
is it in any way justified this is now
you're kind of digging deep okay the
sources of the left-liberal deliberate
misperception and miss you know the way
it's presented is presentation of Israel
Israeli conference on is a fascinating
phenomenon because if you go back to 40
or 50 years right as in the 60s and 70s
the previous century Israel was one of
the left's darlings for numerous reasons
but this has changed now you know we
could spend if you had six seven hours
from the Israeli point of view and
increasingly from the point of view of
Jews across Europe and indeed now and
the United States is that the left
liberal demolition of Israel is
indistinguishable from anti-semitism and
that it should be seen in that light
this is just a got a modern version of
an updated version of very ancient
anti-semitic tropes and and this is a
major issue and arguably the major issue
facing Jewish communities throughout the
Western world and nowhere more so in the
United Kingdom where we have a formally
mainstream Social Democratic Party which
was for many many years various had very
strong and positive relations
with the labor movement in Israel has
been taken over by the hard left and is
now in the view of most people not just
most Jews most people in the UK is
overtly anti-semitic and they cover it
up with this machine of no it's only
about Israel but you know that we no one
accepts that anymore so yeah this is a
major major issue it is not anymore
subject to rational analysis in other
words we can go through all the facts
and figures about the you know the
things I was talking about
multiculturalism and and and mainly many
here at the economic and social and
religious and on and on and on and it
doesn't make any difference because it's
become a dogma and there is a major
problem so you you're of the view that
the labor movement has become
anti-semitic in this country but party
yes in the UK has become anti-semitic I
mean I'm just an observer but you have
seen the you know the the the writers
and another group come and make these
proclamations and and and and I think
that is now the mainstream view as far
as I can judge well 87% of the Jewish
Chronicle put out a poll recently saying
that 87% of British Jews think that
Jeremy Corbyn is anti-semitic well that
yes the Jews are convinced of it yes
right to the point that many friends of
mine are taking the line that yes I'm
romaine and I want Britons remain in the
EU but that is no longer the issue the
issue is the need to vote against Corbin
and prevent labour getting more and more
of their candidates in because laborers
the Labour Party has eliminated all this
Jewish MPs and and in many cases put in
problematic candidates and therefore you
will find that the entire Jewish
community in this country is engaged to
an extent that I've never seen before
right with the
Vinick and a leadership saying you've
got to get out you got a vote vote for
whomever in your constituency has got
the best chance of defeating the Labour
candidate close neighbours aunty submit
and this is accepted by everybody but
we're in unprecedented situation here
and when you think there is a strong
tradition in the Jewish community of
being labour the majority of British
Jews voted labour the older ones for
reasons there was a generation two ago
young ones are reasons to with the basic
by the way let me ask you this why do
you think it is the Jews tended to vote
for left-leaning parties because
normally you expect a community that's
thriving that's economically quite
successful because people get wealthier
they tend to move towards the
conservative end of the spectrum do seem
to be the exception to that trend as I
prefer to say I first of all I don't
claim to have you know real in-depth
knowledge and what I would say is that
there has certainly been a very
significant rift in others I go back 50
years when I was a kid so the
percentages I think they but was much
higher than it would be today if Tony
Blair was a candidate so there has been
a shift to do with moving up on the
socio-economic rankings and so on
nevertheless having said that there is
still a very strong affinity and and
historic relationship with labour which
has only been raptured these last few
years since Corbin became leader and
coming back to the Middle East one of
the things that's happened recently of
course it was the change in Saudi Arabia
with Mohammed bin Salman taking over he
seems to be a whole new creature if I
can put it that way and part of maybe a
broader thing that we'll talk about
which is emergence of these very strong
men generally men leaders around the
world what do you make of him and the
impact that he might have on on the
Middle East well he is having a major
impact in many respects many different
ways so within Saudi
he is leading a push towards greater
social liberalization but at the same
time he has and is behaved and behaving
like a medieval monarch the Saudi
Arabia's mint is a medieval country so
it's been important to understand that
then you can't judge it by any Western
standards because they're just not
relevant so if you know your history in
Britain France and so on your medieval
British history with King Henry's and
John and Richard and you know the stuff
so you had a king who was sometimes
strongest on this weekend you had barons
and Lords and so on around the country
and each of these guys are in here and
their own fief and the medieval system
and the king would try to get taxes in
terms of money in terms of produce and
even if he needed to go to war then he
would say you know you got a surprise
how many many and you said it wasn't the
King around the whole country it was
very much decentralized and if you apply
that model to sword rape you have some
understanding of what's going on right
he even though he is the king he has
difficulty imposing his ideas on the
entire royal family which is a very
large and complex group of people and
beyond that there are many there are
tribes and these tribal units together
comprise I saw the army and the Armed
Forces and there are business entities
business groups one of the most famous
is that bin Laden family knew yeah
they're pretty famous
decided not to pursue a business career
it went in a different direction that
they are very big commercially oriented
family nothing to do with terrorism
estimate so Saudi Arabia's a very
complex place and he is trying to wrench
it out of where it was socially and
particularly economically reliance on
oil and so on and force in a different
direction
and that is very difficult to do in a
very conservative country and and he's
doing this whilst being whilst being
engaged in what is a very deep-seated
struggle against Iran and Shiite Islam
and he's doing it with the American
defense umbrella and a fading away and
so he has enormous problems apart from
those stemming from the fact that he's
young and immature and so there's
objective problems and going to Israel
at the moment right there by the way you
might not know this one of the most
offensive things about Osama bin Laden
do you know this used to be an Arsenal
fan massive one of the main reasons I
disliked him anyway anyway but there is
a major figure in Israeli politics at
the moment who's in a little bit of
bother could you explain what the
charges are against him and what the
impact that's going to be if he's found
guilty on the Israeli state okay asking
you these big questions about a region
that you would probably need a
three-month lecture series to address
and we're giving you about five seconds
to do because you have to kind of
compress it into sound bytes and you'll
have to take your leader as it were
because each one of these so Netanyahu
long political career and long career as
Prime Minister he's been Prime Minister
for over ten ten and a half years
non-stop and before they was Prime
Minister for two or three years I said
we've now reached the end of the road
now you want me to relate to the legal
stuff and the charges and this and the
other but I regard all those very
secondary he has been indicted finally
on a bunch of charges which any or all
of which could be found guilty or not
guilty etc and nobody's gonna wait for
that legal process to play out Netanyahu
in political terms has past his sell-by
date for many reasons the most obvious
of which is that he's been in power over
ten years the Israeli Department most of
these Raley public is tired of him they
extremely tired of his wife that's a
separate story it's very very important
he's an eminence grise has enormous
power of aim and control nunchi he's
involved in many many political
decisions so he is now as I said at the
end of the road what is important is
that this year around let's just not go
through the whole thing this year have
been two electrons neither of which he
won he did fairly well but he didn't win
and he wasn't able to put together to
reestablish a coalition which he would
lead it sounds a bit like British
politics over the last nine years the
fights in this it's the norm yeah so his
political power has considerably been
constrained and it is waning he is going
downhill what is important now now means
today this week
because of the technicalities and
complications of the constitutional and
political situation is that there in
order to get rid of him and save
themselves the senior Lee could people
need to find somebody else
we basically make a poach depose him and
bring in somebody else and they are
trying to muster the guts to do that but
it's very difficult he's very entrenched
if a lot of loyalists and so on if that
doesn't happen this week or next week
then is it all be doomed to have a third
election within 12 months but the code
will very likely do pretty badly and the
worst even lasting lose more seats and
San Antonio is on the way out that's
bottom line oh you slice and dice and
the legal stuff is of relevance but you
know whether he's found guilty and
whether he goes to jail that's way down
the road that's not important let's not
dive too deep into that and blast by the
time this video goes out we will know
what has actually happened so we'll see
if there's forecasts a cure but if we
take a broader step back and talk about
the strong men leaders there seems to my
right in saying that around the world we
have seen a trend of consolidation of
power in China you know Donald Trump is
a very mean in this country we've got a
competition of beta males but apart from
that apart from that we do seem to have
this around the world the obviously
Putin is very strong right now and all
around well do you do you see a trend
there and if you do what is a what what
is it caused by yes it's clearly a trend
and it's a trend only in certain areas
of 19 hours so that right there was an
interesting example just in the Middle
East in the immediate area right and
Middle East isn't it regional you always
had strong men the late unlamented
Saddam Hussein and the
unlamented mr. Gaddafi and so on and so
on but currently you have in Egypt a
president al-sisi who as a military
leader who deposed the Muslim
Brotherhood government in 2013 you have
Mr Al Duan in Turkey who has won power
going back a long time but it's
basically eliminated pushed out all his
rivals and has become terribly
authoritarian and made himself president
and so on Netanyahu is also a good
example if only for the fact that he's
been in power for 10 years is longer
than any other Israeli prime minister
and he has won a series of elections and
so on you have mr. Modi in India which
is a democratic country and he has you
know not only just won elections he's
presented a very different approach to
national leadership and mr. Albin Japan
who is also an elected leader very
similar Tintin Yellin in interesting
ways I put it to my Japanese people that
I might imagine a prime minister who was
Prime Minister for a short time and he
wasn't a good to Posner success and he
lost power and then he a decade later he
managed to return to power and he's been
in power for a very long time does that
sound familiar these are forced to crack
a smile and say yeah that's right
because they media identified with that
baby when well I'm talking about
Netanyahu but it's very remarkably
similar it's very remarkable in itself
is like John Major coming out of her
time and now and unli d'ang the Tories
British the Scottish workers for that
good start like well yeah yeah
this Agreement Bremner online yeah so
this is happening mrs. Merkel was or was
also of that ilk a strong man yeah
seemingly so why is it happening the
simple answer and simple answer usually
very helpful and and largely right is
because in the wake of the great
financial crisis 2008 people came to the
conclusion that what they had been told
and sold was a load of crap and they
wanted people who were giving them some
kind of message of them that made sense
to them and in many countries and this
is the theme that links put in Maadi
uber held one Netanyahu at least all of
those and all ban in Hungary and others
and Trump the theme of make eat whatever
it is great again right restore Russian
and make Japan a serious country and the
same theme runs in country after country
and the people who who promoted these
this theme this idea have done
phenomenally well so that shows that
what people wanted and why they want
that because as you said I think they
came to conclusion that what had been
accepted as the right and proper thing
to do was at least not working and maybe
wasn't of any use anyway
and do you think part of it as well as a
fact that like you listen to Americans
talk and a lot of Europeans they seem to
be this general consensus of you know
the best days of America are over the
best days of your approve and all of a
sudden you've got this person coming in
going no that's not that's not true
that's a lot of nonsense I'm gonna make
America great again sod what these
liberals think let's go forth what Steve
banning calls the manage decline yeah
okay so then you know managed account is
very very fascinating concert
but there's it's complicated right there
are countries that are in inexorable
decline like Japan which they're trying
to turn it around there are countries
online decline like India absolute
opposite of decline but they perceive
themselves as you know needing strong
leadership and and the Congress party or
whoever it is has failed and so on and
then of course you have the extreme
example of Russia where Putin has
succeeded in not just arresting but
reversing some of most dramatic trends
of decline and and weakness and so on
and people respond to them absolutely
and Trump is keeping the same rhetoric
but well course whether to what extent
if at all that's true is a different
matter do you think it's true that he is
restoring America's greatness there's
very little evidence very little
evidence and a man who judges his
domestic economic success by the level
of the Dow Jones Industrial Average is
skating on very thin ice and you're not
one of these people who've got what we
were talking about his Trump derangement
syndrome you you're quite open-minded I
think about some of the stuff but you
don't buy his economic posts about how
the economy is doing lastly by his boats
I mean in other words if you did a
massive tax cutting exercise and you
gave lots of money to certain areas then
you would expect the economy to do most
of the things that it did in 2018 and
that are fading away in 2019 so most of
the serious people might read who are
not victims of Trump derangement
syndrome think that the American economy
is doing badly it's going downhill and
there
we'll be recession and so on and so
forth the problem of course is Trump as
you correctly point out is that it's
very difficult to find people who are
capable of having a rational discussion
in other words and the flipside is is as
we put in as well so and that goes from
Netanyahu with the kind of people you
were talking about earlier right so my
job as it were as a as an analyst and a
consultant is to bring a an objective
assessment of what is going on and in
every one of these cases whether it's
Trump or putting on a Tonya or Mahdi or
whomever you like right so you can say
you know these are his achievements and
these are the areas where he failed and
each one of those open to discussion so
do that was trying to do that for us
what's your objective rational
assessment of his achievements and his
downfalls and by the way that sound you
can hear is YouTube having a meltdown
[Laughter]
first okay Trump's main achievement
globally is that it's very difficult
because he screwed up a lot of things
but he has I think okay you know without
going the whole global thing right he
has kicked the Europeans so hard that
they are now thinking and acting
differently as a wonderful example right
so many people over the years have said
the Europeans are slackers and they
don't pull their weight and they just
live under our defense Sunbrella and
they don't spend any money and so on and
so I have too many naps and Trump came
and screamed at them and kick them in
the balls and now the actually doing
things now it's certainly possible to
argue that his style and all the rest of
it are counterproductive but here is an
example where they've been very
a fairly great cost
Trump is asphyxiating around this is a
very very important thing which is not
well understood at all
even while si is withdrawing from the
middle either everything is complicated
right so people talk about Americans
drawn from the Middle East
Trump cut and ran from Syria to couple
of months ago American power in the
Middle East today is scare orders of
magnitude greater than that of Russia
which is deeply involved in the Middle
East with bases on Salazar
they don't begin to compare so that
American withdrawal and retreat in terms
of actual power has got much more assets
than than the Russians do and so on
so the real issue of course is are you
prepared to use them in what form and
Trump is very clear these make their
entrance on the ground we're not gonna
have our guys killed and Zell would just
blow up other people and and that but in
the case of Iran where by the way
Trump's policy is not one of tweets and
not one of ideas that he thought of in
the bathroom Trump's attitude and policy
towards around is consistent going way
back when he was president for he was
president for he was a candidate for
even thought of being a founder goes
back many many years and his use of
American economic power these are the
Iran is phenomenal right so that for
instance not just the Europeans or the
Chinese oil companies have carton left
because no economic entity in the world
given a choice between losing the
American market and losing the Iranian
market if there's no choice it's not
there's nothing to talk about
so he is asphyxiating which means he's
strangling the Iranian economy and
that's why there are riots in Iran and
and for in tremendous
pressure on the regime so you know you
can joke down list horrible China
Chinese are scared there are what to do
and one of trumps great achievements is
that he has exposed he is raised to the
surface in existence of a very broad
consensus in the American business
community that we've had enough of China
we are fed up with they're stealing our
IP and cheating us and not letting us in
and so now we are really pissed off
about this
and until Trump it was not possible to
talk about that because it was impolite
and now it is okay and every the whole
not the whole massive consensus within
the American business of financial
community supports Trump's approach
towards China and it will roll over to
the next president almost irrespective
of whom that is so those are some of the
achievements that you can give him
credit for you know what other people
don't assume you're a massive Trump fan
and you want to make what are some of
the weaknesses of his presidency what
are some of the dangers I mean obviously
the do tax cut doesn't sound like you're
a big fan of that no Trump has simply
extended the policy of funneling more
money to the top one percent more point
one percent whatever you want to call it
the great beneficiaries in the tax cut
have been the rich ultra rich and the
corporation's who and he has done
virtually nothing for the poor slobs who
voted for him how many jobs have gone
back to America now it's against that
the important thing is a very good right
America has very low unemployment etc
etc that then is true of most European
countries knows most of the Western
economy has record low unemployment and
clearly there is not connected to
transpolar seasons a much broader
phenomenon
you know Trump has not done very much in
sales make America great again
he has considerably intensified maybe
even Poldark and have contributed to the
tensions within American society ethnic
racial etc but I mean you could just go
on and on right the the the the if if
you have reached a point where the
Russians can say with regard to Trump's
SMS or tweet or perhaps even it was a
dramatic telegram of the Carrasco right
he sent a message that one eye president
held one of Turkey telling him in so
many words what he thought of him a song
right and the Russian said that this is
not acceptable so he ripped up the wrong
book on how you conduct Foreign
Relations and he has also gutted most
parts of the American government notably
the State Department many others as well
where there are literally hundreds and
hundreds of important positions which
are not being filled so you know this is
not how to run the country well if the
Russians are setting the moral stand if
I'm an ordinary Trump voter I I kind of
look at the official slogans of what's
happening right he seems to be
addressing the border security issue
right he's trying to build a fence maybe
not a wall but a fence the economy is
booming right big beautiful wolf a big
beautiful fence right the economy is
booming
he's killed al-baghdadi right he's just
he's destroyed I son I'm using all of
this kind of slyly in inverted commas
but these are certainly the claims that
he made I mean you go she's standing up
to China you know that sounds to me like
him delivering on his promises doesn't
know this is no grandstanding this is
all a show that meeting with
Rocketman right Rocket Man he also lets
pretty quickly between calling someone
like the worst person ever and his this
is a serious person and and and most of
what he does is is not serious and in
the best case is is unhelpful and in
many cases extremely harmful
particularly in the longer term and you
know you compare that to some of the I
mean again you're talking about Trump
supporters right the transporters means
people in Pennsylvania and Ohio and
Wisconsin who who turned the election
right if Trump has any claim to genius
and and all the rest of it simply
because he understood that there are
these few states which were going to
turn everything and if he can win them
Democrats will lose and he'll win
although he didn't expect to win but he
that was for how his strategy was built
and Hillary Clinton was most appalling
candidate did not visit Wisconsin from
the Wisconsin primary through the
election and therefore cannot have any
claim to to unhappiness that chief you
know she was gone she did say recently
she's gonna win again she's gonna win
again she said so your support is a
Youngstown Ohio so they want jobs they
want their life and they want the opioid
epidemic and there were long cysts the
first series and things they have not
been those issues are not been addressed
and their well-being is not
significantly improved there are among
the America among the Democratic
candidates people with ideas which would
significantly improve the lives and
well-being of people like that who which
candidates certainly young Elizabeth
Warren some of the others as well right
I mean in
the problem is that some of them are may
are really far out Bernie sounds is very
far out and and some of one stuff is
very far out but Warren at least is a
very rational mainstream person she's a
senator she's been around and she was a
professor and to come from there a
working-class background and and she has
actually thought through these things
that she doesn't it's about slogans and
she would do a lot which would benefit
the people who vote for Trump because by
voting for Trump they are expressing
their disgust at what the Washington
elite has done to them for decades and
there are people on the other side of it
do that Trump will do nothing for them
as done will do nothing for them they're
insofar as they're benefiting that there
are jobs available not good quality jobs
right there are jobs available more than
there were but this is a this is a
cyclical but not use economic
terminology is a cyclical boom and we
are heading for a massive crash and they
are totally unprepared and vulnerable
and why are they vulnerable Pinkus
because their health care system is a
disaster their pension systems on Virgil
collapse they they as a population have
do not have the skills in E they are
uneducated there'll be the clip will use
Americans on in the data you know the
juries in the data there's nothing the
reason young realities are very big
countries 300 million people and they
still have the top hospitals and top
this that and the other and that's fine
if you're at the top but for the bottom
50% it's really bad news and there are
great Suede's in the united states or
the third world countries and Jim
Rickards made the point as well that
there is this massive problem with
student loans yes well now that is a
very specific issue which is a that
people who have
the degrees in Sona buried under these
massive lungs were more substantively
more and more people are getting
supposed to education which is a very
little real value to them but on the
other side of the boundary they emerge
from it with very significant financial
debt which they are going to carry with
them and you know be lucky to pay off at
all so they got little assets in terms
of what they get out of their education
and plenty of her liabilities you know
they spent a hundred grand to get a
Gender Studies degree
well Pincus unfortunately our time is
almost up you're a busy man we've gotta
let you go so before we do that we've
got one more question for you and the
question always is what's the one thing
that we're not talking about as a
society that we really should be talking
about demography and having children
okay tell us more the well everybody in
the West the whole of Europe Eastern
Europe so more even than Western Europe
suffering from demographic decline right
we talked about Putin Putin managed to
stop the rot and he's brought it back
son wants a people beginning to have
children and they're not dying at the
age of 48 from liver malfunction from
drinking too much vodka right to booze
not some very very serious achievements
so the big now United States is
incredibly in ten years ago was not
impossible things those things is now in
serious demographic decline the people
we were talking about the Trump voters
they don't have children they they die
young American life expectancy is going
down and so on and so on right so the
the developed world is facing a
demographic crisis now you can argue the
same is true in China so but Europe
North America Japan South Korea and so
on these are countries in very
serious demographic crisis whatever you
want to call it which by the way is why
the pension system is going Bastable one
of the main reasons and having children
has gone out of fashion and people have
very good arguments that I they can't
afford it and so on but that simply
brings you back the government right you
can have policies that remove some of
the obstacles that having children that
doesn't mean everybody have children
most of these policies don't work
because of other factors but people want
to have children say I can't have
another child because the cost of
childcare Ozone right the woman won't go
out to work just their home it's that
whole syndrome to parents both or to two
income families right so if you're down
to one you're already on the borderline
these things can be addressed now you
can argue that all the effort so far
where this in Japan or France or
wherever they haven't succeeded but
given that this is literally existential
you would expect that it would
constraint considering more attention on
the part of policy makers and voters
well they go so stop using contraception
and have as much sex as possible that is
our message for this week since
trigonometry I think is Linda thank you
so much for coming on really appreciate
your time as always follow us at trigger
pod and we'll see you again in a week's
time with another brilliant episode so I
go see you next week guys thanks for
watching guys as always subscribe to the
YouTube channel click the bell button
next to subscribe button so you get
notified when a video comes out and
follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod and also leave us a nice
review on iTunes and spread the word
you